60 km reliant jouy en josas à heymans et
c'est la piste cyclable inaugurait mardi
13 septembre à chevreuse au château de
la madeleine le conseil départemental a
présenté ce parcours un trajet qui
s'inscrit dans un projet global celui de
la vélo ceni 450 km courant de paris au
mont saint michel
ce que je trouve très bien dans ce type
de projet c'est qu'il est vraiment
transversale on traverse une région on
traverse plusieurs régions on traverse
plusieurs départements aux traverses
plusieurs communes tout le monde s'y met
avec un fédérateur un vecteur fédérateur
qui rit sept vélos ceni pour ce nouvel
itinéraire le département a investi plus
de 3 millions d'euros la région ile de
france les collectivités concernées par
ce tracé ont également subventionné le
projet au cours de leur périple les
cyclistes sont amenés à découvrir les
richesses du territoire un moyen de
favoriser le tourisme
nous cherchons véritablement à faire un
développement autour de ça avec des
restaurants des hôtels des gîtes des
maisons d'accueil de façon à ce que ce
que ça devienne vraiment un tourisme en
développement économique c'est le
fondamental du département nous avons
une vraie volonté aujourd'hui au niveau
du département de développer tous qu'ils
sont tous les pépites des pics culturel
à patrimonial ou naturelles des dizaines
de curiosité sont à découvrir en
pédalant cinq sites inscrits au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco ponctuent
le parcours de la vélo ceni au total
elle traverse quatre régions et huit
départements